[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre sur tv soixante
dix huit pour une nouvelle édition du 7
8 politique
au sommaire de la prochaine demi heures
rencontre avec bruno myle yens député
modem des yvelines il se charge
notamment du grand débat national sur sa
circonscription elle mais ce grand débat
ne risque-t-il pas d'entraîner de grande
déception tant les attentes sont grandes
nous entendrons aussi jean frédéric
poisson l'ancien député président du
parti chrétien démocrate est l'auteur de
l'islam à la conquête de l'occident nous
parlerons de son ouvrage mais aussi de
la place qu'il entend donner à sa
formation lors des prochaines élections
et puis retour sur l'actualité politique
du mois avec la création d'une nouvelle
commune le chesnay au concours et puis
les voeux des élus qui se poursuivre en
ce mois de janvier bruno milieu dont
jour j un député des yvelines vous allez
organiser une dizaine de débats sur
votre secteur
après les cahiers de doléances de la
grande consultation nationale on entre
là dans la seconde étape vous en
attendez quoi vous en tant qu'élu est de
ces débats d'abord je veux rendre à
césar ce qui lui appartient
je participe effectivement à ces débats
mais c'est sous l'impulsion de
l'association des maires ruraux les
yvelines donc soient plus longs
notamment de sylvie geste en son son
président a effectivement on s'est mis
en tête d'organiser un certain nombre de
débats je pense qu'on va faire une
dizaine sur la circonscription il ya un
an' prévu aussi sur bûcher donc ça fait
à peu près de 11
les dates seront connus à la fin de la
semaine vendredi les dates définitives
de manière à ce que les gens puissent
s'inscrire mais moi j'attends que les
gens viennent surtout moi je serais pas
là en tant qu'animateur chocolat sur
certains débats pour écouter surtout
écouter beaucoup écouté les gens parce
que je crois que c'est la première des
choses qu'on a à faire c'est écouter
leurs revendications à écouter leur mal
être écouté toutes ces choses là qu'ils
ont besoin de dire et puis ont tiré les
conséquences derrière alors ce que
j'attends de ce grand déballage écoutez
franchement je l' ai déjà dit sur
d'autres plateaux mais si on se lance
dans cette opération nationale de grande
envergure pour écouter des français
c'est pas pour qu'au bout du compte ils
en sortent rien parce que silence rien
autant qu'on se mettre la corde au cou
tout de suite et ont cependant choses
qui sortent aussi en russie on se base
sur les cahiers doléances jusqu'à
présent en retour de lier cette
revalorisation des retraites contre le
l'immigration aussi quelquefois avec les
débats on est ce que vous craignez aussi
qu'il y ait trop de choses abordés vont
prendre à répondre à tous là vous avez
que sur la plateforme on est à peu près
à 100 milles contribution aujourd'hui
bien évidemment de ces contributions
vont émerger des sujets plus prégnant
que les autres
c'est ce qu'il faudra traiter en premier
lieu aura comme un ordre prioritaire
naturel en fonction de ce que les gens
auront abordé après la façon dont on les
traitera il y aura sûrement du
législatif
est ce qu'il y aura ou pas matière à
faire un référendum très peut-être et à
ce moment là il faudra voir si on le
fait ou pas mais en tout cas il faudra
répondre sur ces sujets prégnant parce
que la colère on l'a bien vu
elles datent pas d'hier je pense que les
gens on avait déjà plein les bottes
depuis bien longtemps
l'étincelle ça a été la taxe la taxe
gasoil qui a fait déborder si je puis
m'exprimer le réservoir est à partir de
la bombe à ses montées et en dehors de
certaines manipulations de certains
extrémismes qu'on a pu voir la colère à
des réelles dans une grande partie de la
population pas seulement qui porte ce
qui porte un gilet jaune avec rigby
restant l'a vu dans les communes ya des
gens qui sont venus remplir les cahiers
de doléances qui portait pas de gilet
jaune conquis remonte de ses cahiers
jusqu'à présent pas beaucoup de justice
beaucoup de demandes de justice fiscale
et sociale
un paradoxe quand même énorme c'est à
dire plus de pouvoir d'achat mais moins
d'impôts donc il ya quand même un
paradoxe qui fera qu'on explique aux
gens aussi quand même que la partie
sociale des dépenses représentent 32% du
pib
donc il ya bien un moment les services
publics oui plusieurs villes à risque
public plus de service publique et moins
d'impôts donc ça c'est un petit peu
paradoxal il va falloir qu'on trouve des
solutions pour répondre à ça rien est
impossible en peu de chance c'est que le
numérique et la digitalisation peut nous
aider mais faut pas le faire n'importe
comment sur point les services publics
par exemple moi je veux pas donner de
solutions là on verra ce qui émergera
mais il me paraît évident qu'on peut pas
maintenir certains services publics avec
des personnels dedans quand personne n'y
va par exemple
donc c'est l'idée des maisons de service
public c'est une bonne idée mais ça pose
un problème parce que s'est posée en un
lieu pas forcément accessible par tout
le monde autour donc il va peut-être
falloir imaginer des agents des supers
agents du service public polyvalent qui
puisse être itinérant est allé à la
rencontre
à la rencontre des citoyens parce que
même si on met de la digitalisation au
travers du présentiel supposé tout de
même cette question en ouverture est ce
qu'on ne va pas vers une grande
déception aussi est-ce que vous la
craignais cette déception on pourra pas
tout satisfaire je veux pas mentir on
pourra pas satisfaire toutes les
exigences il va falloir qu'on satisfait
à celles qui sont les plus importantes
et qu'on explique surtout pourquoi les
autres mais moins importantes on peut
pas les satisfaire et donner un projet
vers lequel on avance pour essayer de
satisfaire quasiment l'ensemble des
préoccupations des français
il faut vraiment là qu'on soit non pas
dans la communication politique ou dans
la communication politicienne dans la
communication du projet qui va sortir de
cette grande consultation avec des actes
forts tout de suite sur les sur les
choses des plus prégnante et puis des
solutions à court et moyen terme qui
passeront peut-être par la loi mais
qu'il saura qui saura mettre en place
vous parlez de communication politique
lorsqu'elle emmanuel macron tu vas
rencontrer les maires remonte ses
manches et discuter avec eux pendant
sept heures est-ce qu'on n'est pas là
dans une séquence de communication
politique aussi moi je pense qu on est
surtout là dans une séquence de re
tissage de liens avec les maires qu'on
avait perdu ça c'est franchement un truc
aussi sur lequel nous groupe modèles
dont c'était un petit peu contre cannes
c'était un peu élevé
alors d incompréhension je sais pas si
le lien était complètement rompu mais en
tout cas il y avait des incohérences ont
été abandonnées en tout cas c'est à
versailles avant même le mouvement des
lillois c'était le ressenti des mers
donc il fallait aller rediscuter avec et
bien évidemment on est là je vais
emprunter une phrase à gérard larcher
comme qu'on peut ne pas du même parti
est d'accord sur certains points
gérard larcher a raison de dire que la
commune c'est la petite république dans
la grande tout part de là alors les gens
ont besoin de plus de démocratie au
niveau national ça c'est clair mais on
peut faire la même la même chose pour
répliquer c'est au niveau local il avons
besoin au niveau local on sait très bien
que sur certaines intercommunalités ou
sur certains départements la démocratie
on va dire participative ou citoyenne
n'est pas tellement représentés on a un
exemple qui ressort en ce moment et ça
n'a pas dû vous échapper avec le
mécontentement notamment sur la
restauration scolaire des collèges des
yvelines alors qu'on nous avait promis
que ce serait servie qui fait ce serait
que ce serait mieux que ce serait
fantastique on passerait bah non c'est
pas fantastique nous mais on n'a pas
consulté on n'a pas écouté des citoyens
n'a pas écouté les parents là dessus par
exemple je reviens ce débat national à
ces échanges qui vont avoir lieu en cas
de des chèques malgré tout en cas de
déception puisque vous l'avez dit
vous-même vous ne pourrez pas satisfaire
toutes les exigences et toutes les
demandes
vous n'avez pas peur d'être au premier
plan au tant qu'élu ben s'il faut être
au premier plan on se remet au premier
plan on est là pour assumer aussi non
y'a pas de soucis jusqu'à présent s'est
jamais dérobé
donc on se dérobera pas voir tiendra
notre rôle jusqu'au bout
il faut qu'on explique beaucoup moi je
n'aime pas le terme pédagogique ce
pédagogue ça s'adresse à des enfants et
citoyens sont pas des enfants
j'aime bien le terme explication il faut
vraiment connectique moi j'ai reçu des
gens chez moi beaucoup ces derniers mois
il va beaucoup sont venus à la
permanence quand j'ai chez moi c'est la
permanence et je me suis aperçu qu'il y
avait aussi une grande méconnaissance
des institutions et de leur
fonctionnement
donc il faut continuer a expliqué mme
bouthillier tout à l'heure que vous les
élus les députés ne se dérobe pas
jusqu'à présent mais néanmoins est ce
que c'est vous la politique que vous
vouliez faire votre engagement lorsque
vous l'avez pris donc là au sein du
modem est affilié avec la république en
marche pour les élections législatives
il ya maintenant deux ans c'est la
politique que vous vouliez faire vous
vous attendiez à devoir aller comme ça
explique et non pas faire de la
pédagogie mais en tout cas expliqué
réécouter retisser du lien il ya quelque
part une part d'échec
ya eu des erreurs notamment de
communication temporalité des lois ça je
veux bien l'admettre
et puis peut-être qu'effectivement on
n'a pas parce que les choses se sont
enchaînées très très vite on n'a pas
suffisamment expliqué ça c'est possible
mais sur le projet en tant que tel
l'idée du projet c'était quand même de
libérer les énergies pour permettre à
chacun de pouvoir entreprendre que ce
soit au niveau salarial ou au niveau
entrepreneurial en tout cas libérer les
envies libérer une espèce d'autonomie
des citoyens face face à la vie de tous
les jours et de l'autre côté en même
temps essayer de protéger
on a fait la phase de libération ça tout
le monde l'a bien vu et ont commencé à
faire la phase de protection d'espèces
de matelas de protection pour les
citoyens les plus les plus défavorisés
la meilleure preuve c'est que les
solutions d'urgence mises en place par
le gouvernement finalement c'était
quelque chose qu'on aurait dû faire
d'ici à 2022 et qu'on a fait d'un seul
coup donc c'était présent à l'esprit
maintenant on va peut-être pêché d'abord
parce qu'on a été très vite parce qu'on
sait que si on veut réformer un pays
c'est dans les deux premières années
parce qu'après c'est compliqué donc on a
travaillé on a passé un maximum de loi
pour libérer la france et notamment pour
redonner de la compétitivité aux
entreprises parce que même si les gens
veulent pas l'entendre mais il faut
quand même que 10 des entreprises pour
qu'il y ait des emplois
donc voilà donc sonné on a libéré sa
dans cette phase-là lit et c'est vous en
parlais tout à l'heure on est en cours
d'évaluation il n'est pas interdit alors
on reviendra pas en plus qui essaye n'a
pas été supprimée pour tenir il était
transforme en effet ce n'est pas tout à
fait la même chose donc on verra
l'évaluation ce que ça nous a rapporté
moi je sais qu'il ya déjà eu ça
rapportait de l'argent parce qu'il ya
déjà eu des investissements dans l'outil
productif français maintenant il faudra
évaluer combien et apporter les
ajustements
peut-être que peut-être que sur cette
partie sf on n'aurait peut-être pas dû
changer de cible
il y est c'est fait puis dire voilà on
garde on garde les ss en revanche tous
ceux qui investiront dans l'outil de
production français j'entends bien
français et qu'ils peuvent le prouver on
les défiscalisent reims était peut-être
plus simple
bon voilà il ya eu il ya eu oui il ya
peut-être eu des erreurs commises mais
l'intention de départ du projet est bien
seul à libérer les énergies et protégé à
côté parce qu'on est dans une société
aujourd'hui à une évolué qui va avoir
une évolution très forte en matière
d'emploi on est en pleine mutation vous
voyez bien que l'emploi salarié
il va être de moins en moins important
au profit peut-être de l'auto
entreprenariat ou en tout cas peut-être
même au profil des deux c'est à dire une
part de salariale à une part
d'entrepreneuriat l'auto entreprenariat
on voit que les choses sont en train de
changer avec l'intelligence artificielle
avec la digitalisation ça bouscule un
peu tous nos repères c'est normal que
les gens soient inquiets en cas d'échec
est ce que la dissolution sera la seule
solution aujourd'hui on entend parler
aussi de blocage politique de
difficultés là on imagine mal des lois
passées en ce moment de toutes façons
des lois elle peut se passer en ce
moment il ya quand même une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale je viens désastre
mais les questions sur une faune se
compliquer pas forcément il ya des avis
divergent mais ça fait partie des
démocraties et puis moi je suis j'ai
toujours été partisan d'une assemblée
forte pour qu'on ait un gouvernement
fort je pense que plus les
parlementaires que ce soit l'assemblée
nationale du sénat seront forts comme un
petit peu ce qui est à l'image des états
unis dit d'ailleurs plus le gouvernement
peut tout ceci dit c'est pas ce qui a
été entendue jusqu'à présent sur cette
assemblée ces députés avec un pouvoir
fort on a plutôt entendu que les députés
étaient là pour être une chambre
d'enregistrement sur le début du mandat
c'est parce que les gens schématise un
petit peu c'est pas vrai on n'avait pas
vécu comme ça en tout cas moi je vais
pas vécu comme ça en tout cas dans notre
groupe
à chaque fois qu'on allait apporter des
choses dans les apporter même si elles
n'ont pas été acceptées même si on a
perdu mais en tout cas on va porter ce
qu'on pensait juste de portée merci
d'avoir participé à ce 7,8 politique et
donc les différents débats qui vont se
tenir dans toutes les circonscriptions
dans le département et puis même au delà
merci encore dans un instant nous irons
rencontrer le président du parti
chrétien-démocrate auparavant retour sur
la fusion effective maintenant depuis le
début du mois de janvier là d'euros
concours et du chesnay une nouvelle
commune mais dans quel but éléments de
réponse avec ce reportage
le chesnais et rocquencourt sont
officiellement mariés après plusieurs
mois de délibérations les deux communes
ont officiellement fusionné lors d'un
conseil d'installation programmée ce
mercredi 2 janvier aux chaînés la fusion
est un
et un acte d'avenir un acte ii
un acte logique dans la mesure où la
fusion permettra de réaliser des choses
que nous ne tuons pas en mesure de faire
jusqu'à présent de réaliser des
économies d'échelle et puis de gouverner
avec beaucoup plus de d'aisance et de
facilité de rendre un maximum de
services à la population
lors de ce conseil dix sept adjoints ont
été nommés jean-françois peuvrier ancien
maire d'euros concours a notamment été
désigné premier adjoint de la ville pour
le poste de maire l'ancien élu du chéné
philippe brillault seul candidat prend
la tête de cette nouvelle commune
baptisée le chine et rocquencourt
il a obtenu 48 voix sur 57 après un vote
à bulletin secret moi c'est la première
fois que je suis amené à gérer une
commune toute nouvelle qui a que
quelques heures
donc cela nous a appris avec
l'administration
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de l'égalité
et beaucoup de réinitialisation de la
commune en bref une bonne remise en
cause de tout le monde ça fait du bien
et ça va rebooster nos deux communes
prochaine étape pour la vie nouvelle du
chéné rocancourt définir le long de ses
trente trois mille habitants
la décision devrait être prise à la fin
du mois de janvier lors d'un prochain
conseil municipal le mois de janvier est
également marquée par les nombreuses
cérémonies de voeux des élus du côté du
département la cérémonie s est déroulée
conjointement avec celui des
hauts-de-seine de département qui
souhaiteraient bien eux aussi se
rapprocher un peu plus les deux
présidents les républicains des
départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine réunis au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en ce début
d'année une cérémonie de voeux en commun
pour des discours très politique dans la
ligne de mire de pierre bédier et
patrick devedjan le gouvernement et son
grand débat national
ces débats je le crains nous nous
réjouirons que les chaînes d'information
continue et les plus extrêmes trouveront
de toute façon à mettre en scène lui et
contentement du peuple et les deux
présidents de demander plus de liberté
pour la nouvelle année liberté notamment
de poursuivre le rapprochement de leur
département afin d'obtenir la validation
du projet de fusion nous avons rempli
toutes les obligations légales
qui permettent la fusion donc le
gouvernement est mal venu de considérer
ou de déclarer qu'il y a trop de
collectivités locales que ceux-ci
génèrent des coûts nous nous proposons
au contraire de fusionner et nous avons
répondu à toutes les obligations légales
pour ça et le gouvernement fait la
sourde oreille
je veux dire à l'étape qu'il n'a pas le
monopole de l'intérêt général que nous
partageons l'état et les collectivités
ce souci de l'intérêt général et qu'il
faut sortir de ce système très archaïque
d'un état centralisateur neta qui décide
de tout parce qu'en l'état décide de
tout rien ne marche
un seul mot d'ordre donc au cours de
cette soirée décentralisation pad
annonce de nouveaux projets en revanche
pour le moment yvelines et
hauts-de-seine partage notamment un
service de voirie ou encore
d'archéologie et d'adoption second
invité du 7-8 politique pour ce mois ci
jean frédéric poisson ancien député des
yvelines actuel président du parti
chrétien-démocrate bonjour vous nous
recevez ici dans votre permanence à
rambouillet avant de parler de votre
formation politique des élections
européennes de l'actualité on va parler
de votre ouvrage l'islam à la conquête
de l'occident et pour bâtir cet ouvrage
nous est parti d'un document la
stratégie de l'action culturelle
islamique à l'extérieur du monde arabe
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
sur ce texte qui date du début des
années 2000 c'est un texte qui a été
adopté et votée par les 57 états
musulmans du monde entier qui sont
réunis dans une grande organisation qui
s'appelle l'organisation de la
coopération islamique ses 57 états qui
s'inquiétait de la manière dont comment
dire la charia la loi islamique et la
communauté musulmane s'affaiblissait en
occident ont résolu donc d'écrire un
document qui est un plan stratégique
d'action pour étendre la charia sur mode
occidentale principalement sur l'europe
ce document est officiel il est public
il est disponible en français sur le
site isesco un.org i/s esc au point org
chacun peut aller lire et verra que
l'intention est très clair même si elle
est répartie assez discret pantech
paient en deux endroits on parle à un
endroit de la volonté d'installer je
cite une civilisation de substitution à
la société occidentale
donc remplacer notre culture par la loi
islamique et un deuxième en droit on dit
qu'il est nécessaire de tout faire pour
je cite à nouveau installé une société
islamique pure et saine en occident fin
de citation l'a également donc les
intentions sont claires et ce document
est officiel ce qui m'a donné évidemment
envie de le faire connaître à mes
contemporains
on va rentrer un peu plus en détail sur
ce texte mais déjà comment vous
expliquer qu'il ne soit pas plus connu
que ça a c'est un mystère pour moi parce
que quand la deuxième organisation
interétatique du monde l'organisation de
la coopération islamique publié un
document stratégique destiné à
l'occident aussi clair que cela et je
vous parle du texte français mais il
existe en français en arabe et en
anglais
le texte français parfois un peu
arrondie le texte anglais n'est pas du
tout il est beaucoup plus sharp commandé
en plus pointues et comment dire et
direct une forme de paresse d'abord une
certaine forme de peur s'est tant qu'il
est encore en occident difficile de
traiter des sujets en vérité sur la
question de l'islam
la volonté de ne pas donner aux
musulmans occidentaux l'impression
qu'ils seraient maltraités volonté que
je partage
pour maintenir le dialogue avec eux mais
ils peut-il y avoir un dialogue sans la
vérité c'est difficile à imaginer
et puis quatrièmement je pense une forme
de une forme de négligence ou de
faciliter les états qui soutiennent
cette stratégie principalement des états
du proche orient en termes financiers
culturellement les pays du maghreb
principalement le maroc et l'algérie qui
se livre comme vous savez dans des
mosquées en france une forme de guerre
d' influence très compliqué et très
vives
tout cela fait que une forme de paresse
et de trop grandes conciliation d'esprit
de conciliation avec ses différents
états nous conduit à ne pas vouloir
surtout il traitait ses questions donc
je vous remercie de me donner l'occasion
d'en parler ça n'a pas sifflé mais
quelle serait la bonne réaction
politique aux d'abord il faut d'abord
prendre conscience du fait que ce projet
est un projet politique
déclinée sur le champ culturel soutenu
par des états la réponse ne peut donc
pas être comme c'est trop souvent le cas
en ce moment de laisser les maires faire
face à des phénomènes d'islamisation qui
ne savent pas traités parce qu'ils n'ont
pas les moyens de faire donc à cette
politique culturelle menée par des états
il faudrait prendre par une politique
culturelle menée par l'état
à commencer par refuser tous les signaux
d'islamisation qui sont malgré tout le
monde roule en france ça pose les
questions des menus à la cantine des
horaires réservées dans les piscines la
question des prières de rues qui ne sont
pas autorisées du financement des
mosquées les angles culturel qui
camouflent des mosquées ou des écoles
coraniques qui camouflent des mosquées
qui ne respectent pas les thèmes des
termes actuels de la loi de 1905 et un
certain nombre d'autres choses comme ça
qu'il faut absolument refuser
et puis se dire que après tout il s'agit
aussi de savoir ce que nous voulons
faire notre civilisation
donc soit effectivement nous renouons
avec notre héritage pour mieux préparer
l'avenir pas pour se complaire dans des
choses qui sont passées mais nous sommes
ce que nous sommes parce que des
générations nous ont précédés nous ont
transmis une langue une culture des
savoir faire etc qui sont enrichis aussi
avec beaucoup de contacts bien entendu
mais nous devons réapprendre à aimer
nous même notre propre civilisation pour
être capable de la transmettre à faire
valoir je suis persuadé que si nous
étions un peu plus attaché à la
transmission de notre propre patrimoine
au sens large du terme
sans doute qu'on le rendrait plus
attractif à l'égard de ceux qui ne
trouvent pas dans notre manière de vivre
aujourd'hui de quoi les satisfaire
quand vous parlez de notre patrimoine au
sens large est ce que vous entendez
aussi réaffirmé les signes de chrétienté
peut-être n'ont pas nécessairement parce
que nous sommes de culture chrétienne à
défaut d'être un peuple qui à la fois il
est chrétien je j'insiste beaucoup sur
ce point parce qu'on peut pas comprendre
beaucoup des éléments de l'histoire de
france de notre droit et nos
institutions si on n'a pas ça en tête
les français sont je sais pas très bien
comment dire
on va dire qu'ils sont une hostie comme
on disait il dit se doute qu'il ya
quelque chose là au dessus ça pas très
bien quoi mais mais beaucoup d'entre eux
pensent en tout cas même s'il ya des
gens qui n'ont pas de fouad religions se
sont hâtés ce qui est leur droit le plus
strict moi je ne me bats pas pour autre
chose que le fait dans la sphère
politique car c'est ma responsabilité de
faire valoir
précisément cette évidence que nous
sommes enracinés dans des concepts dans
des notions dans des institutions dans
un système de droit qui sont marqués par
le sceau de la culture chrétienne
les français n'ont plus tellement
confiant pourtant c'est la vérité même
ce qui vient des lumières sans racines
très largement dans cette tradition
aussi est en fait ce qui est intéressant
c'est que ce str ap c'est un document
stratégique de l'oci lui la firme
parfaitement le fait que les
civilisations sont différentes et
qu'elles sont irréconciliables c'est
même son point de départ
alors à défaut de vouloir à tout prix
faire la guerre ce qui n'est pas du tout
mon sentiment
enfin si long de la fête vous faut que
je réponde et si on nous l'a fait il
faut répondre
leleu la démarche l'affrontement
culturel qui est organisée par les états
musulmans aujourd'hui nécessite que nous
y répondions d'abord sur le plan
culturel donc du ré enracinement lorsque
nous sommes pour vous poser clairement
la question est ce que votre ouvrage est
à rapprocher de l'idée du grand
remplacement non c'est vrai on peut
entendre nos noms qui vise à remplacer
donc par était musulman par la culture
la cleansing la théorie du grand
emplacement les démographique plutôt que
plutôt que culturel même s'il ya des
même s'il ya des incidences non ça n'est
pas à manger jeu ce n'est pas une
hypothèse que je déroule encore une fois
je suis parti d'un document qui est
officielle et politique c'est le public
qui n'est pas contesté d'ailleurs par
personne j'ai lu ce document simplement
et je vois qu'il ya cette volonté de
remplacer notre civilisation par l'islam
donc je dis 1 voilà ce que veulent un
certain nombre de gens voilà ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire parce qu'il ya
une très grande ressemblance entre ce
qui est écrit dans ce document qui a 18
ans maintenant et ce qui se déroule sous
nos yeux vos confrères davet et l'homme
en publiant de livres inchallah il ya
quelques mois ont montré ce qui se passe
en seine-saint-denis et dans des
yvelines pas très loin d'ici
un peu au nord pour ça que je mets en
poussant cette direction on a des
phénomènes qui sont très comparables
vous savez très bien que en ville
nouvelle où dans le nord du département
nous avons des territoires qui sont
absolument dominer maintenant par la loi
islamique a remplacé dans une très large
mesure valeurs républicaines c'est quand
même un problème
je n'invente rien je regarde j'essaye de
déterminer les causes et les causes sont
en politique parce que les états unis
demandé dix idées et deuxièmement tout
ça est enracinée dans la plus pure
tradition islamique donc c'est un
problème qu'il nous faut traiter
j'ai écouté vos différentes interviews
pour la sortie de cet ouvrage justement
alors je vais vous citer l'islam n'est
pas une religion universelle l'islam
religion de tolérance de paix et d'amour
oui mais contre musulmans uniquement
mais c'est vrai puisque donc c'est
incompatible avec le fait de vivre
ensemble sur le territoire français 6 à
6 à la condition que ceux qui ne sont
pas musulmans inquiète de soumettre à la
loi islamique
c'est d'ailleurs le régime que
connaissent tous les non musulmans qui
vivent dans des huttes à temps des états
musulmans que ce soit en afrique du nord
au moyen-orient ou en asie moi je n'ai
pas d'animosité à l'égard des musulmans
je le dis clairement j'ai un problème
c'est pour ça que je critique l'islam
comme système politique et religieux
c'est mon devoir de responsables
politique et philosophe par ailleurs pas
de le faire maintenant
je dis aux musulmans c'est simple si
effectivement vous avez l'intention de
propager ce qui est votre système de
références politiques et religieuses qui
est votre droit à ce moment là nous
allons nous affronter assez vite si vous
ne souhaitez pas le faire et que vous
souhaitez conserver à l'expression de
votre religion les atours d'une fois
pacifique et s'expriment dans des
conditions décentes je n'ai rien contre
ça c'est même mon devoir de responsables
politiques de protéger cette expression
mais il ya une limite à cela et le
moment est venu que dans la société
française on s'entende sur cette ligne
pour en revenir à l'actualité du moment
et le grand débat qui débute un peu
partout en france est-ce que vous pensez
que cette thématique nous voient revenir
sur le tapis devrait s'exprimer aux
signes elle ne devrait parce que j'avais
dit pendant la campagne des élections
primaires
la présidentielle il ya deux ans que de
mon point de vue d' islam était l'un des
sujets centraux du quinquennat qui s'est
ouvert il ya un an et demi bientôt deux
ans je maintiens absolument cette
affirmation d'ailleurs je vois que
chaque jour qui passe ne fait que
confirmer cette impression qui était la
mienne à l'époque à l'évidence cette
question fait partie des sujets qui les
interroge les français qui les inquiète
même parfois sans compter ceux qui
vivent au contact de cet islam
triomphante qui existe en français qui
n'en peuvent plus là on n'est plus dans
l'interrogation d'exaspération sinon le
fait qu' ils s'en vont purement et
simplement dans que oui bien sûr ça
devrait faire partie des sujets puisque
l'on parle de la contestation un
politique justement elle s'exprime aussi
à travers donc les gilet jaune quel
regard vous avez sur cette mobilisation
plus largement on sort du cadre du grand
débat mais de la contestation des gilets
jaunes va d'autant qu'on a appris qu'une
liste pour les européennes pour exister
suite à la création d'un mouvement gilet
jaune je comprends très très très
profondément et je respecte infiniment
cette revendication est la dignité qui
est exprimé par le gilet jaune
beaucoup d'entre eux ont le sentiment de
vivre dans un pays dans lequel il n'est
pas possible de vivre des fruits de son
travail ce qui est une atteinte très
très violente à la dignité humaine et
vous savez la tension que je porte que
nous essayons porté au parti chrétien
démocrate sur des questions liées à la
dignité donc je comprends cette
revendication j'observe que elle
s'exprime certainement très au delà de
sa manifestation habituelle sur le
pouvoir d'achat je pense qu'à des sujets
bien plus importants de considération de
reconnaissance qui sont qui sont qui
sont portées donc ce mouvement
à supposer qu'on puisse le considérer
comme un mot gêne ce qui est déjà un
exercice un peu périlleux ans en lui
même
comment dire ah
rejoint certain nombre de préoccupations
d'ailleurs qui sont les miennes et
toutes les variantes de la défend sa
dignité humaine de sa quille en a
beaucoup en ce qui concerne leur volonté
de constituer une liste je pense qu'ils
vont pas tarder à se heurter alors
d'abord à tous les problèmes pratiques
de constituer une liste nationale de 79
ans et tout ce que ça suppose de
contrainte parce que ça n'est pas un
exercice si simple que ça deuxièmement
sur quel projet politique ça c'est quand
même le sujet parce que tout le monde
s'interroge sur des projets politiques
qui sont portées par les différentes
listes nous aimeraient de la france avec
nicolas dupont aignan quelques autres
amis nous avons publié notre projet pour
l'europe donc il est connu il est
constant chacun connaît les positions de
nicolas dupont aignan et les miennes sur
les questions européennes
troisièmement j'observe qu'il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui se réclament
du mas candille historique qui intègre
la liste des gilets jaunes donc je me
demande s'il n'y a pas aussi une
tentative d'infiltration ou de
constituer une liste et demi ma croix
niaid en quelque sorte pour s'assurer
que tout se passe bien
voilà donc attendons de voir j'espère en
tout cas que si jamais il est entré dans
le débat européen et qui entreront sur
des questions européennes et attentat
sur des problématiques techniques le
pouvoir d'achat est la première
préoccupation j'observe que ce n'est que
secondaire mans une question une
question européenne mais nous verrons
bien alors vous l'avez évoqué avec les
amoureux de la france que vous avez
fondé avec nicolas dupont aignan vous
allez vous vous engagez pour cette
campagne des européennes programme
défini liste aussi défier les parents
comment on est en train de la
constituent et petits gnoti vous serez
vous-même candidats probablement
probablement est probablement la
troisième place de cette liste
très bien merci beaucoup jean frédéric
poisson nous avoir reçus on aura
l'occasion de reparler bien sûr des
européennes c'est la fin de ce set 8
politique on se retrouve le mois
prochain sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]